ragazzi siamo a viterbo la linea
gianmarco enrico e insieme e
collaboriamo questo canale da un paio di
vita tanto tempo che arrivo delle
richieste su un più e nei fatto dalle 4
e il video intendono intende perché non
abbiamo mai fatto prima ha deciso di
farne uno e con mostra anche sorpresa ci
siamo resi conto che se avete un sacco
di domande
bando alle ciance iniziamo subito
vediamo insieme come dividete le entrate
loro sono stipendiati da te scusa so che
è privata ma non è così privato secondo
me come noi lavoriamo gratis in favore
dell'italiano
chi di voi è più precisino al lavoro più
precisione lavora nella linea la linea
lavenia la linea e questo fa capire che
il seno sono i suoi dietro la vigna ma
molto prima che lavorano insieme stia
rovinando ballo rafforzando il vostro
rapporto che si è molto più forte del 20
per ottaviano a trattare vi odio tutti è
il mio caso lo sta rafforzando io
proprio una forma di rapporto speciale
perché oltre nelle regole della
parentela abbiamo un rapporto di persone
stanno costruendo insieme un qualcosa
che sta andando bene a volte sono anche
le frizioni e il continuo confronto che
ti permettono di scoprire degli aspetti
di una persona che a volte anche se
sarebbe trovata da i due anni nel mio
caso specifico perché sono giovani siano
magari non conoscere e mario invece a
livello umano con enrico scio sempre
avuto il rapporto perché siamo coetanei
ma cui erano nella vigna in particolare
ho costruito un rapporto che prima non
avevo sinceramente un rapporto giovani
invece per quanto riguarda mi è cambiato
nulla mentre stava raccontate un
aneddoto imbarazzante che comprende
tutti una figura di merda di gruppo la
corale non posso dire tutto uno di noi e
mail della vergogna estate l'altra tale
il quale cerniera chiesto un parere da
uno di noi su un'attività è stato
risposto tipo regata ma fa schifo una
oxa e clientele copia sotterrarsi sono
stati miei più [ __ ] da una
linea telefonica gioco dando gianmarco
per una semplice ragione quando c'è da
ordinare ogni volta il pasto è sempre
puntualmente gianmarco in anno bene
niente e dire solo otto perché voi
preferite mangiare del rispetto a
lavorare cosa ti servono e mezzo al mare
ma bisogna lavorare ai dei quattro
scoperti più americano tyson e devo dire
che è stato
la di gianmarco tu ti sei auto candidati
che io mi sono messo la faccia
marco il nostro coniglio e anzi ho qui
per cui dei video anche voi proprio
abbiate fatto voto di castità nella vita
tutt'altro ho una fidanzata che sta a
roma per i coach e la napoli che quei
giorni che ci vediamo cosa ci facciamo
concorrenza per un po la linea che
nell'oscurità che son venuti da viale
guglielmo è uno che insomma poco
racconta di come vi regolate quando non
siete d'accordo sulla decisione
importante che tali cortona storia hanno
poi siamo troppo che disaccordo alla
fine i titolari insomma secondo me
prendono la decisione finale come è
giusto che sia di vetro entrambi i
titolari a voi duran che scorre
chiaramente ciascuno in base al proprio
settore di competenza ha un peso
maggiore rispetto agli altri più basso
tra gianmarco i capelli e le date è una
domanda che si sta facendo
gabriele lavia è tutta una copertura
anche senza filtri o nico di battuta
pronta po fuori dalle righe bene cavallo
pazzo di voi è il più prolifico a
livello di idee governo ma che davanti
aveva 100 il pittoresco saroyan nessuno
io sono solo un uomo
se potessi vivere per un giorno la vita
di uno di loro quale sceglieresti perché
mangia marco perché scopo un botto e
dico così vado pure affanno trovatina
palla io pure la linea manco morto
perché c'era penso che uscire totalmente
devastato psicologicamente gianmarco
manca molto e dico no grazie ma fiducia
invece sceglierà i biglietti non voglio
provare la giusta per lui armi e solo
che la linea visto le persone volevano i
signori del talent assicurava intera
vita di gianmarco ercoli
la cosa più bella che avete fatto
insieme un'orgia grillo sicuramente si
anche sanremo è molto bella sanremo dati
sulla neve non sono venuto qui ecco in
picchiata sulla pista rossa my two piano
b o vi siete buttata anima e corpo in
questo meraviglioso progetto un ed io
faccio anche altre perché sono avvocato
però sono anima e corpo il progetto io
feci capire che per la tv ha mai provato
ad insegnarvi la pole dance è ovvio a
questa milan gianmarco ed enrico sul
palo
se ne va in quanto 155 zione alzano e
faccio male a te visto favore mi sono
recato nella regione con l'immagine tema
è di almeno ti sei capito bello ma come
immortale cose apprezzate l'uno
dell'altro il loro silenzio che carina e
niente di lavinia la determinazione di
enrico qualcosa che sa perché ha un
carattere buono però che alcuni dati del
suo carattere non mi piacciono e
guglielmo ha prezzo
l'intelligenza io non è che apprezzo
sono cose che vorrei io per me allora io
alla vigna vorrei rubare la capacità di
multa casting di gianmarco vorrei rubare
la capacità di organizzarsi e la
freddezza che a enrico vorrei rubare
l'estero quale lavoro avreste dovuto
fare se non fosse andata bene la società
di famiglia a me piacerebbe fare
l'astronauta
mi sono rivisto interstellar di recente
dello spazio all bellissima e venere la
domanda perché cosa aver saputo fare
alla strada io avremmo mai uno che
faccio l'avvocato che nella versione
dovendo grado nello spazio anche il
medico mi è sempre piaciuto ma sempre lo
spazio da quando ci sarà un nuovo studio
siamo alla terza trattativa abbiamo
avuto a che fare con due studi che per
uno di oltre un altro non ci piacevano
ci saremmo stati a che fare con persone
colli dove erano solo buone energie
quindi questo terzo ufficio cele
sfaldando vediamo allora le strade ben
definito l'anno prossimo chi dei quattro
è il più sfigato in amore ragazzi questa
frase di capaci per laden e ha cioè nel
senso che sono proprio più stia tocca
capire quanto è sua responsabilità e
quanto e degli altri secondo te 50 50 da
lì sono d'accordo ragazzi appelli
accorati call to action
ho pianto niente niente
superpotere quale scegliereste perché
deve trasporto
anche io così posso andare su marte
morire per il controllo del tempo ma
danno curare mamma tu avessi questo
dell'umanità dell'umanità
vorrei tossire bombe ciao a tutti i
magnifici 4 45 inter ti telefono mite
per un video e poi a realizzarla
innanzitutto in ufficio e tirare fuori
un'idea per un video ma si dice in
termine tecnico che a cacare le ater in
rete però altre volte può capitare che
invece hai mangiato così tante fibre che
come sapete che stavo pensando
la domanda era i fantastici quattro e
vive la coppia sono mister fantastic
io sono un ragazzo invisibile che fa la
giocata da patrick preferito e acqua può
essere no no come nel tuo dio perché
della ma forse l'acqua frizzante il mio
la sambuca perché era bagnata vice qual
è l'oggetto che non condividere se mai
con nessuno
la mia acqua bucks salina io mi accordo
con lo spazzolino perchè tanto lo so non
mi viene ma il tuo spazzolino
condividere sti mi è capitato se non ne
faccio un dramma
chi è più bravo a cucinare a mtv è brava
a cucinare mai
io so fare di bene alcuni piatti
dobbiamo ancora fare la sfida di cucina
quello sancirà il più bravo tu sei fare
quattro piatti gianmarco e facciamo una
sfida io e te
guarda come ha paura e lo smer diamo
guarda adesso le forti la canzone disney
preferita e cantate lo so come zone
tramonte in assoluto tra le canzoni di
ricchezza non mi piace per mia di eni
conti verso un mondo di incanto
principessa e tanto che il tuo cuore
aspetta sì a me piace tanto quella di
mulan
io voterò parola di moana intendere come
fa scusa io ve lo dà anche a me piace
molto pochi i pochi tvp di quanto invece
personaggio disney preferiva nell ad ade
è il miglior cattivo probabilmente
mazzarella ma a me piace molto frollo
ridicola fluide lame mai fatto bene ma è
caratterizzato bene hanno preferito
no no è il primo che mi viene in mente
siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video
vi invitiamo a iscrivervi e attivare la
campanella delle notifiche o mettere un
55 mila in su senza 55.000 la prossima
ciao